my pickums are in shambles phase is out
G2 is out Navi is out everything we
thought was going to happen didn't that
leaves us with two questions what the
is going on and two who is going to
win CS Go's last major
[Music]
so it turns out in my last video I was
absolutely correct the Paris major is
turning out to be the most unpredictable
tournament in CS go history all of the
story lines that were set in motion to
potentially cap off the end of this era
basically vanished Into Thin Air Nico
will never get his CS go major and
simple won't be Crown King one last time
dude they've got to be a little bit
worried about that showing up as
Kerrigan though oh my
Cinema all and he will get grenaded out
of it but he brought his team a chance
broke like he's not done yet and you're
right there is a flight coming through
they're not ready for it rain gets a
kill and it's all on The Gulch one
versus two to try and keep his team
alive keep the dream alive for them well
they're right up behind him the flick
not connect again he is brought down
Brookie to send Navi out of the major
and phase they made the comeback into
overtime into double overtime and they
have done it in Phase limps into the
playoffs and end the dream of a final CS
go major for navi for simple for
electronic their legacies End early now
despite all our pickums being cooked the
dream of a storybook ending is still
very much alive but before we get into
what that might look like let's talk
about how we got here the Challenger
stage immediately kicked things off with
some pretty surprising upsets although
the big three eventually made it through
top 20 teams like Mouse OG and Payne
fell in dramatic fashion it's right up
above them Dexter with one and
nothing further here from Mouse this
then led to a ton of Cs go fans and
Talking Heads levying some complaints
against the tournament system and if
you're new to these all too common
gripes allow me to explain to start off
the way the seating Works often leads to
some brutal matchups you know when two
teams with equal skill and following
have to face off in elimination rounds
early on for a tournament to be as
engaging as possible you're going to
want to see the best matchups further
down the line and although it's cool to
see unknown teams do well it's sometimes
hard to get the same viewership for that
however the seating and qualification
problems are just the tip of the iceberg
people's real problems lie with the best
of one format in the Challenger and
Legend stages best of Threes are
exclusively reserved for decider matches
so if a team is advancing or being
eliminated time and time again this
leads to really good teams falling
behind early now the very common
Counterpoint to this is just win your
matches and while there is some truth to
that we are missing some Nuance as I
also said in my last video the skill gap
between teams has all but evaporated
everyone's gotten very good at shooting
each other in the face so what it really
takes to win a match comes down to
strategy and over the course of Any
Given year the top 20 teams in the world
often face off against each other so the
majority of their strategies are based
off of those experiences which is
exactly how a team like liquid can lose
to a team like force liquid has never
faced this roster before in contrast
liquid is probably the most dissected
team in the history of the game so
Forest has plenty of odds to study now
take away the skill Gap and make it a
best of one and that's how you get an
upset Molotov smoked out you know that
peak's coming OC just waiting and
shelfie does the exact same thing Molly
is not on top of the bomb it doesn't
spread oh she's gonna stick it all the
way or not selfie in the dying seconds
sends liquid to the O2 group however
this is is nothing new we all knew what
the format was going to be heading into
this so there's no real surprises when
like this happens that being said
nothing could really prepare us for the
second stage to kick things off nine and
Furia would be the two teams to go 0-3
and while maybe we all hyped up the
Polish Squad a bit too much Furious
performance was unbelievably
disappointing listen I am an outspoken
Brazil enjoyer but you can't deny that
over the last few years even given their
ups and downs Furia has been the most
electrifying team to watch but seeing
them fail to get a single t-side round
in two best of ones I mean it's clear
that they just weren't there as a team
and as many echoed on Twitter I think
it's best to just forget this
performance and maybe it won't be what
the boys are remembered for now
fortunately for me Furious disaster
showing wasn't even the biggest low
light of the legend stage Navi and G2
two of the best teams in the world have
been eliminated and won't be in the
playoffs which is a pretty big deal now
the story of Navi getting knocked out is
its own can of worms I'm serious it's
some real anime ass we're going to
need to do a separate video so just stay
tuned for that but if you're an outsider
all you have to know is that simple the
greatest player of all time will not be
on stage for the final CS go major
unfortunately things get a lot worse
because on the other side you have G2
and Nico not only has Nico one of the
most mechanically gifted players in the
world never won a major but he came
within an arm's length twice before and
both times he failed in spectacular
fashion at this point there are probably
no words to describe how Nico fans are
feeling right now but I know damn well
it can't be any worse than the things he
has to say for himself nothing really
much obviously didn't deserve any of
them I was close many chances has
slipped away
uh
new chapter starting in CS2 and that's
it okay just got super bummy I'm
sorry so let's bring things back up
because we still got a ton of Cs left
and there's a lot of cool outcomes we
can see so who really has a chance at
winning this major game religion Monty
Apex sure why the not literally
anything is possible at this point but
if we want to look at the big guns what
are the options well vitality and heroic
are still the most consistent looking
teams out there as I expected they have
both made it through without a single
loss so once again if I were a betting
man it's a coin flip between them two
slight Edge to Vitality but that's the
thing I'm not a betting man I'm a man of
passion and loyalty to my region and by
God if liquid had a chance at winning a
goddamn major it's now they started off
this tournament by getting absolutely
balanced by Apex and force I erased them
from my pickums out of spite but they
proved everyone wrong and clawed their
way back with a vengeance that's the
nature of this Bianca role right you you
go nothing to 100 oh
enough he is giving 100 right now oh for
the ace and he's gonna get it Oshi and
especially Naf are putting up major MVP
numbers right now and if they all get
their together I honestly think
they have a good chance at this that
being said for every team left there's
one hell of a journey ahead of them but
win it all and you will forever be the
final Kings of Cs go
uh we did one before and I also named it
Paris major Roundup so this is part two
it won't be named that obviously you
you just go Paris manual Roundup too and
like people are like six billions yeah
critical could do that video and it
would do like four million we all knew
this was going to be the format going in
so I don't really under Underpants I
don't really Underpants